and i
am
iron man
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and today
i have a
really special video a two-part video
collaboration with
the canadian lad the canadian lad is an
awesome youtuber who watches videos at
.25 speed and breaks them down finding
things that nobody else on the internet
is talking about right now
and we're going to be answering the
question why didn't doctor strange
revive tony stark in avengers end game
again it's a two-part video so be sure
to head over to the canadian lad
after you finish this video now this is
a big question that everybody has been
asking since avengers in-game
why didn't doctor strange revive tony
stark
there were plenty of ways to do it
especially with all of the infinity
stones
literally on tony's body especially with
captain marvel there who would have been
more than capable of handling another
snap
well here are three very compelling
reasons
why doctor strange never revived tony
stark
reason number one an infinity war when
the scarlet witch destroyed the mind
stone along with vision a massive
explosion set out the entire surrounding
environment was shook
it even knocked back thanos well once
thanos got close to where vision was and
reversed
time he managed to bring back both the
mind stone and vision
back from the dead however he also
brought back that explosion
meaning bringing someone back to life
using the time stone also affects the
surroundings
something similar could happen to tony
if time were to be reversed
and since the last thing that he did
while he was alive was to decimate
thanos's army
if doctor strange tried to bring tony
back he could also possibly be risking
bringing thanos and his army back in the
process
and thanos is an extremely intellectual
being and a savage when it comes to
combat
he could have quickly turned and fought
to get the stones back if he had come
back to life
this is a risk that strange no doubt
could have thought of and could have
possibly saw in one of his 14 million
different scenarios when he went forward
in time because we know for a fact that
he went forward
this far in time now say that doctor
strange was perhaps not going to just
use the time stone but use
all of the infinity stones to bring tony
back well that brings us to reason
number two why doctor strange didn't
revive tony stark the infinity gauntlet
and or nano gauntlet can't actually
bring anyone back to life
that died now of course your first
thought will be but hulk snapped and
brought back the half of the universe
that was snapped
so it can bring people back to life
right
well there is a technicality here a
technicality that the russo brothers the
directors of avengers infinity war
and avengers endgame slightly hinted at
and that is
the people who were snapped were never
technically
dead they were technically wiped away
from existence
or as thanos put it in infinity war they
ceased to exist
with all six stones i could simply snap
my fingers
they would all cease to exist and i call
that
mercy the russo brothers in an interview
after avengers infinity war
stated that thanos didn't technically
kill anyone he wiped them away from
existence
and they kind of hinted at the
possibility of everybody that was
snapped being
in soul world but that really never came
to fruition in avengers end game however
they did say that thanos technically
didn't kill anyone he wiped them away
from existence now
this is very very particular phrasing
perhaps death and being wiped from
existence are two
very different things in the marvel
cinematic universe the mcu's
metaphysical reality has not yet been
established but
if there's any kind of an afterlife the
infinity gauntlet may not have power
over it
because remember the infinity gauntlet
in the movies is not the same as the
infinity gauntlet in the comics
in the comics thanos could snap as many
times as he wanted to without getting
even a little bit hurt
in the movie when thanos snaps the first
time it destroys nearly half of his body
and when he snaps again it almost
kills him much different from the comics
even nebula in the comics could snap and
not get hurt
and in the movies the russo brothers
said that in order to use the gauntlet's
powers
you had to close your fist this is
demonstrated on the titan scene when
doctor strange tells his cloak
don't let him close his fist so thanos
couldn't use the gauntlet
don't let him close his fist
[Music]
the point is is that the gauntlet in the
movies is very different from the
gauntlet
in the comics and may not have the power
to bring people back from the dead
who are in the afterlife completely
perhaps this is also why the hulk
couldn't bring that back in avengers in
game even though as he said
he tried to perhaps it had nothing to do
with her being the sacrifice for the
soul stone
but more with the fact that the gauntlet
just doesn't have that power
since she was actually dead from a fall
and not from the stones
the same could be said about vision and
quicksilver why didn't they come back
why wasn't the gauntlet and the stones
used to bring them back
well the gauntlet may not have that
power and perhaps that's why strange
couldn't use the stones to bring tony
back
the third answer to why tony stark was
not revived in avengers in-game
is a very interesting answer and the
answer is that tony stark
had to die and doctor strange knew it
now doctor strange knew that tony had to
snap and he knew that he would die in
the process
but once tony snapped and thanos and his
army and the threats were gone
why didn't he bring it back after what's
the threat well the threat could have
actually been tony himself
remember this is the guy that created
the iron legion
tony made the iron legion just because
he entered a portal in the first
avengers film and had a glimpse of the
threats that the earth
might someday have to face his ptsd from
the first avengers film resulted with
him creating hundreds of other iron man
bots
and then he built ultron tony stark
literally ended up creating old tron
just because of a vision that the
scarlet witch made him see
or should i say scarlet witch was the
one who realized
i don't have to plant any ideas on his
head because his own desperate measures
will bring destruction upon this world
now imagine if tony survived the snap
and realized that he wasn't being
paranoid and that the earth
actually does need a defense system much
like ultron
what would he end up doing this time
around if only his ptsd can cause him to
create the iron legion and
ultron then what repercussions do you
think would grave from his experience
from the final battle of avengers in
game
had tony survived he would basically
have every right to say
i told you so to the avengers which
would only boost his already massive ego
couple that with the mountain of
vibranium from wakanda since they had
opened up five or six years prior to
in-game
and the access he had to the six
infinity stones and you start to see why
it might be a good idea to let the man
die and sacrifice
and this could have very well been one
of the features that dr strange saw
in which tony stark again brought about
the destruction himself
again there are probably many ways that
they could have brought tony back
the time stone itself all of the
infinity stones and doctor strange is
the master of the mystic arts he
probably could have figured out a way
but in the end he knew that tony stark
had to die and therefore could not
revive him
i hope you all enjoyed this theory that
me and the canadian lad came up with
together
be sure to go over to his channel and
check out his part of the video
as i mentioned this is a collaboration
video and i'll have you know that he is
one of my
favorite youtubers like i said he is
making videos that nobody else on
youtube is taking the time to do and his
breakdowns are
absolutely insane he watches movies like
avengers in-game avengers infinity war
the justice league at .25 speed and
finds a ton
of different hidden little easter eggs
and little details that everybody else
on youtube is missing i wish my
breakdowns were as good as his and we
both plan to bring you some more
breathtaking content
in the future so be sure to go over and
subscribe to his channel and
let us know in the comments down below
what you thought about this theory be
sure to leave a like and subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
content
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you